Howdy, master, princess!
Welcome back, master, princess!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello!
I sound a little bit better today, I think.
A little bit stuffy.
But not as bad.
I think I'm getting better.
But I feel like I'm in Dimension 5.
I think...
I took a sleep time medicine.
The ones that help you sleep.
I feel like I'm in a different dimension today.
I feel like I'm in...
How did you end up sleeping?
It was funny because I woke up at 1 AM.
And then I was like...
I looked at the clock and I was like...
1 PM!
I slept until 1 PM!
And it was 1 AM.
Oopsie.
Are you okay?
I'm okay!
I'm okay.
Why would you take that before stream?
What was your endgame?
What?
The medicine?
It was to sleep!
You still haven't finished Indiana Jones?
Okay.
Maybe if you were going to criticize me on not finishing the game yet...
You should not call him Indiana Johns!
This game is long though.
I didn't realize it was so long.
But I'm having fun with it.
Indiana Johns.
Indiana Jonas.
Sorry.
Get well soon!
Thank you!
Don't stand in the rain like Indy.
Coughing baby.
Are the meds why you ended up kissing paper 13 times?
Look, I will not explain any context.
I don't have to explain anything to you guys.
I don't have to explain it.
For those who don't know, I tweeted about it.
I practiced kissing paper 13 times.
Was anything on the paper?
Nope.
I was just practicing.
Hi, I'm a piece of paper.
Animator, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Usually my cough ends up getting really bad at night.
So I'll be like decent-ish all day.
And then at night my cough gets really, really bad.
Hopefully, I'll be okay.
Hmm...
Is it for ASMR purposes?
No?
Look, I don't have to give you guys anything.
I don't have to tell you guys anything.
I can just tweet things.
It's my afterlife.
Let me do what I want!
Let me do what I want.
What if I ask nicely?
No.
Now is the time for me to do the coughing baby.
I don't want to be coughing baby!
I don't want to be coughing baby.
I want to be cool Indiana Jones.
You don't have to, but what if you told us because you like us?
Look, I will be explained in time, okay?
You must be patient.
No!
Giggly E.P.
Vito with cute Mito.
What was I going to say?
Oh, I was going to do a recap of Indiana Jones because it's been a while.
It's been a while since we last played Indiana Jones.
It's been a while.
Can't wait to see you this weekend.
Wait, are you going to a danny party?
I've told them... I don't know.
I was like, singing is kind of...
I'm going to do my best.
Please, I need this.
So, recap.
Should I do a big recap or just a small recap of what happened?
Let's do a big recap because it's been a while.
So, Indiana Jones...
He was working at school and a big giant man broke in and stole a little cat mummy.
And he's like, no, my cat mummy.
I love that guy.
He stole his cat mummy figurine.
And so he had to travel to Italy.
Why?
Why did he choose Italy?
Something...
The giant guy had a Vatican thing.
He had a Vatican medal.
Yes!
So he had to go to Italy.
And we were like, sneak, sneak, sneak, sneak.
And we found stuff.
We found a big tomb of giant people.
And I had to punch a giant in the face.
Pretty awesome.
And then we found out that the cat mummy was actually not a cat mummy.
It was actually a thing.
Pinky!
It was a piece of...
Hold on.
There are some things that create a great circle.
No, not an infinity stone.
There's something...
And then there were other things.
Like one was in...
One was in...
Mexico.
No.
Somewhere.
And they also found...
Egypt was next.
Yes!
That's where we went from.
We went from...
We went from Italy and we went...
All the way to Egypt.
And then we went sneak, sneak, sneak.
And I also punched more people there.
And...
There was a haunted cave.
But it actually wasn't haunted.
Which was kind of disappointing.
And...
It's raining where I'm at too.
So it's extra immersive.
The great pyramids of Mexico.
No, I got ahead of myself.
I was thinking about the boat.
But that wasn't Mexico.
I can't remember where they did that experiment.
I can't remember.
But anyway, hold on, hold on, hold on.
We went to Egypt.
And we...
Found like a really crazy cave thing.
And it actually had a giant alive...
Oh, well, there was a live giant before.
At the Vatican.
But that guy kind of sucked.
This guy was like really old.
Probably like so old.
And he didn't like us.
He was just like, hey, don't say that name.
And we were like, what name?
I'm gonna say the name.
And...
Then we got buried in the sand by the bad guy.
And we had to punch...
No, we had to blow away scorpions.
Because apparently they're very aggressive.
Yeah.
And...
We heard where they were going next.
And they were like, we're going to the Himalayas.
Because there was something else there.
And so we go.
And we see a big ship.
That was like the coolest part of the game so far.
I'm not gonna lie.
We went to find the missing boat that traveled through space and time.
Into the hilltops of the Himalayas.
And it was like, whoa.
And all the people on there were frozen.
And you're like, whoa.
And then I go, sneak, sneak, sneak.
Punch, punch, punch.
Sneak, sneak, sneak.
Punch, punch, punch, punch, punch.
And...
We found the capitan.
Who had a thing that we needed.
And then we say the spell.
Because the boat collapses.
And we say the spell and we're transported to Shanghai.
And we're like, whoa.
I don't have to sneak there.
All I had to do was fly a plane.
And...
From Shanghai, we flew a plane.
And now we're here.
Oh yeah, we found the lady's sister.
Because she was working with the baddies.
Maybe against her will, maybe not.
It's questionable.
Rest in popsicle.
She became a popsicle.
She was frozen.
Howdy, Minto.
Tips cowboy hat.
Glad to see you with less snot.
I have an equal amount of snot, I'd say.
Yeah.
Classic missing sister move.
I sure hope not.
Thanks Minto for the retelling of the past streams of Indiana Jones.
I was really busy when you streamed them.
Oh, no problem.
So, this recap is kind of questionable.
Wait, no!
I hit all the big points, did I not?
I think so.
Did I miss anything?
You did great.
You did good.
Thanks for the spark notes.
Hi, Minto.
Hello, hello.
Nope, that was all, I think.
You basically got it.
You should describe the one fight scene where the Nazi doctor guy jumps like a monkey.
They're so goofy in this game.
Everybody is so goofy.
I love it.
What's the great circle?
If you have the great...
It's...
The great circle.
The circumference.
With it comes a great responsibility.
And then you say, I missed the part where that's my problem.
Oh, no.
Isn't it like...
Isn't it like a bunch of the wonders of the worlds are placed in a circle?
And you go there and there's...
There's pieces that also make a circle.
And also, then you get great power, probably.
I think she's making this up.
I'm not.
It's an ancient donut.
Fullmetal Alchemist plot.
Is that really the plot of Fullmetal Alchemist?
It's been a long time since I watched that.
I actually never watched Brotherhood either.
You mean the pyramids?
We went to the pyramids.
The pyramids had...
Giants underneath them.
Oh, what are they?
Oh, Iris.
Iris is one of them.
What are they called?
Nephilims.
Nephilim.
Sounds like something from Winnie the Pooh.
You have heffalumps and nephalims.
You must correct this immediately.
Brotherhood is so good.
I liked when I watched the original Fullmetal Alchemist.
I saw the movie too.
I never saw Brotherhood though.
But Brotherhood is more accurate to the manga, right?
Thank you.
Sorry, I spooked you.
Biblically accurate Winnie the Pooh.
So let's continue.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I'm gonna have to remember all the controls for this game.
Oh, I forgot too that it's in first person.
Oh my goodness.
Elephant.
Anything around here?
I'm gonna have to remember the controls.
Oh geez.
Okay, I know how to punch.
This is block.
Oh, that's punch.
That's punch too.
Keralese.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
We got jump.
This is block.
Put them fists away.
Put it away.
Indy.
That's whip.
Crouch.
And I can change outfits and food and everything here.
I know how to put it away.
It's all coming back a little bit.
It's coming back a little bit.
Can I break this?
Break that.
Nope.
Wait, am I supposed to be sneaky here?
I'm just gonna wander on in.
Darksiders 1 is a Legend of Zelda inspired post-apocalyptic game where you play as a Nephilim.
Highly recommend it.
Kinda like DMC Combat.
Thanks for the suggestion.
Let's see.
Comic book.
Albino Crocodile God versus the Reptile King.
That's quite the title.
I collect all the comic books.
I love those.
Am I supposed to be sneaky here you think?
Am I free to just wander?
I can't read.
I'm gonna wander until someone gets mad at me.
Hello?
Wow, that's a lot of apples.
Surely they wouldn't mind me taking...
Like this guy is not gonna get mad at me, right?
Hello?
She looks tired.
She's going ghost.
What's this?
A recipe.
Tom Yum Goong recipe.
Look at the guy on
the...
Kinda looks like you guys.
Interesting.
Serve and watch him squirm.
Excuse me?
That rude German asked for food.
Because I want to watch him burn, we will make my famous Tom Yum Goong.
This is how you do it.
You prepare a batch of shrimp and make stock out of the shells and heads.
Strain out the bits and add 3 stalks of lemongrass, 7 lime leaves, a large root worth of ground galangal...
And 20 roughly chopped chilies, including the seeds.
A birthday!
It means that was my birthday today and since my hard drive is too small for MGS5...
Oh, and my hard drive is too small for MGS5 since Mother Base can't sing me happy birthday, would you mind?
Of course, Ben!
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday, with salutations!
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you, Ben!
Happy birthday!
After 5 minutes, add the shrimp and take off the heat.
Add chili paste, fish sauce, and lime juice until it tastes right.
Serve and watch him squirm.
Go to the market and shop this.
Chili paste until it is spicy enough.
Dang.
I think I would...
Why did you say that?
I like spicy.
What if I...
Whip her?
Okay.
Is this fish?
It's a lot of fish!
It's a lot of fish.
And he is a man of taste.
That's me when I pick up a doujin.
Mmm, spicy.
I like spicy.
How are you?
You okay?
He's just shuffling along.
Umm...
Okay.
I love exploring in this game.
I know that's probably what makes this take a bajillion times longer for me.
Oh!
Anything for me to steal behind you?
No?
I don't think you're asleep.
Oh, sorry.
Your eyes are open.
I don't think you're asleep at all.
Are you cold?
You're shivering a little bit.
What the hell was that?
Did you know that a Swiss photographer who traveled to Egypt in 1988 was presented with an 11.8 inch finger?
What?
Yaoi hands are real.
Corn.
Guys, is corn a vegetable?
I did the thing earlier that was like, this is a psychological test.
And it asks you questions like, oh it is?
Okay, thank god.
It was like, what's 1 plus 1?
What's 2 plus 2?
What's 4 plus 4?
What's 8 plus 8?
And obviously I got all of those correct.
And then it said, name the first vegetable that comes to your mind.
And I said corn.
But apparently, most people think of carrots.
Corn is not a vegetable.
Gregor Spory.
Okay, I'll look him up later.
Oh no, you didn't bring your clothes in!
Shame, shame, shame.
It's a kind of vegetable.
I'm getting mixed messages from you guys.
I'm getting mixed signals.
I don't know who to believe.
Oh yeah, we're at the hotel.
Hello.
Oh, news article.
Sukhothai article.
The foreign archaeological delegation visiting the ruins of Sukhothai has been marred by accusations of thievery.
It was an internet psychological test.
Oh, Gina's talking to herself again.
I can...
Witnesses claim that the soldiers accompanying the archaeological expedition as protection against rebels have been stealing valuable historical artifacts intending to ship them back to Europe.
The general of the Royal Siamese Army in the Sawankhalok region dismissed this as baseless rumors.
This expedition was sent by Italy's great leader Bonito to exchange knowledge benefiting both our countries, she said.
According to the general, the archaeologists will work with local scholars for a few days studying the ruins before they return home.
We should be proud by the global importance of our history, he added.
Voss is that one...
That one guy.
That one...
He's the baddie.
He's the main baddie we're fighting right now.
Fast hands.
Revolver reload speed has increased.
I got them fast hands.
Yeah, Huey Voss.
Right?
Hello.
He's just scratching his chin.
Is anyone looking at me?
Stealing their bread?
Stealing... I'm stealing their food?
No one's looking at me?
Oh.
Hello.
Hey.
No one's looking, right?
They're gonna scream if they see I'm taking their food.
Just... hey.
Simple.
Hey.
What is up over here, though?
Anything of interest?
Can I make a phone call?
No.
There's lots to explore around here, okay.
The bread isn't yours.
It is now.
Have fun.
Oh gosh, there's so much to explore in this area.
Okay, that's how you run again.
Yeah, so I'm fine.
I don't need to be a secret around these guys.
Unless I'm stealing their money.
Hello.
And he says hi to everyone.
So nice.
That was an American greeting.
Get him!
What's up in here?
I hear Gina still.
Gina, give it a rest.
Okay.
I give up.
Let's go break in, maybe.
Ciao!
Soggy bread.
No, it's not soggy.
Where is she?
Hello.
Hello, ladies.
Oh, she is inside?
Oh my god.
I'm not eating the stalk.
That's very confusing.
Hi.
Hello.
Tomato is actually a fruit, but considered a vegetable in culinary...
This is why things are so difficult.
Yeah.
I hope your sick goes away.
Thank you.
Okay.
Starfruit?
I love starfruit.
Starfruit.
This is...
This is fruit food for everybody, everyone.
Probably.
Flood rains hit the Sawankalak region.
Many regions in Siam are grappling with the aftermath of an exceptionally intense monsoon season.
A hot dog is an open-faced sandwich.
We're not having this conversation.
Banana, actually a berry.
No.
It would need to be more juicy.
I would like a room.
One region in the province of Sawankalak, known for the ruins of Sukhoktai, where rice fields and villages along its rivers have been inundated.
Tourists are advised to stay away from the area, as normal travel routes will be limited or inaccessible for some time.
Monsoon season hit hard.
Let me in.
Oh, we need the storage key, eh?
Alright.
Okay.
Next thing you know, B is also a fish, probably.
Hey, can I get this room?
Carrots used to be Resident Evil.
I'm just so shocked, though.
Room key four.
That...
It could be both a fruit...
And...
And a vegetable.
That makes no sense.
Are you gonna help us get a room?
They're trying, they're probably just like, get a room.
But how am I supposed to?
Rebel attack.
Oh, sorry, rebel article.
Following a series of violent rebel attacks...
Ow!
I didn't make that up.
On the foreign expedition of Sukhothai, the general has vowed to end the bloodshed.
Soldiers will now... I wanted violence.
I thought I made up the violence, but it actually happened.
I'm craving it.
Soldiers will now accompany the expedition to ensure their safety.
This should not concern the peaceful residents in the area, said the general when asked about how this would impact the villagers around the Sukhothai ruins.
The soldiers are only there to protect everyone from the senseless violence committed by the rebels.
The rebels have been active in Sukhothai since the failed uprising in Krang Thep, which caused many to flee north.
Fight back, people.
Rise up!
The Vatican declared capybaras as fish so Christians could eat them during Lent.
Who is eating capybaras?
What?
Oh.
Okay.
I don't remember what I'm supposed to be doing.
Wait, hold on.
There we go.
Okay.
We have this nice pretty little sketch that we did of the hotel.
Trouble in paradise.
Sukhothai, one of the sites on the Great Circle.
There must be a stone hidden somewhere in the ruins.
Marcus Brody has access to all sorts of research back at college that could prove helpful in finding it.
Okay, so we're gonna call him and be like, hey buddy.
Hey Brody.
Brody, Brody.
Brody Mc... Brody.
Oh my god, Gina, give it a shot, please.
Marcus, did you find the page?
Sukhothai.
That's what I thought.
Hey, shut up.
I mean, what's wrong with meeting a person?
What's wrong with talking to a lady?
Oh my god, we're fired.
Wait, actually?
No way!
They fired Indiana Jones?
Oh my god!
It's him!
It's the big giant.
The first giant.
Hello?
Thank you so much.
Very helpful.
What?
Did nobody...nobody notices this is happening?
VA is so good, right?
Voice acting in this game is awesome.
Oh, he hung...
What happened?
Say it.
Say a ghost.
Say it!
Well, it took me a while, but I finally got us some rooms.
Oh,
she got us one room.
Take the room key.
What if I don't?
How much will she bother me?
Indiana!
Indiana, take him with his bones!
Indiana Jones!
Oh my goodness!
Indy, no!
Ok, I'm taking it.
Thank you.
Goodbye.
Where did that guy come from?
Where did that guy go?
Indiana Jones.
He shouldn't be threatening me though.
We are trying to help.
No.
This is my room.
I'll leave my door unlocked.
Actually, no.
I'll leave my door locked.
I got attacked by a giant.
Oh yeah, free bread!
No!
Hold on.
Munch?
Munch.
Nice.
I didn't think this would kill a cutscene.
Wow, the moon is beautiful.
Indy?
Do you hear me, Indy?
It washes everything clean.
Oh, that's his sister.
We can see the moon so well during monsoon season.
It's kind of crazy.
Mood killer.
Oh my god, I can't believe we got fired.
I was just kidding, but I can't believe we actually fired him.
She?
Indy?
Yeah, but that's on you, Indiana Jones.
Oh, she wanted you to be a house husband.
Why is he like...yeah.
What is this atmosphere?
You do have a heart.
But you are still a grave robber.
Indiana Jones.
No!
Oh god, Indy.
We just got this room.
Oh my god, the monkeys are going crazy.
Wait, let me in!
Gina!
Gina?
Damn, she's fast.
She already ate the apple.
God, she's fast.
Ok, hold on.
I forgot to pick this up earlier.
Forgotten page of a journal.
I've arrived at the hotel, far from the busy halls of Chulalongkorn University.
I can feel the serenity of Sukhothai settling on me, even though I've only been here a short while.
I needed this change of scenery, just as I need to work in the field.
As much as I love old books, I have to uncover the truth myself.
Is grave robber like cradle robber, but for ghosts?
What's a cradle robber?
Aptly named since you forgot to take it.
Spawn camper?
What?
Baby Minky.
What do you mean?
Don't worry about it.
Nevermind, don't worry about it.
Huh?
I'm scared.
What?
Not for YouTube streams.
You are a ghost.
Just don't Google it.
Some people are saying Google it.
Don't worry about it.
Ok, I'm gonna not worry about it.
Wait, what is it?
I'm scared though.
Anyway.
I have to uncover the truth myself, following in the footsteps of Prince Vajiravood, as he explored the ruins of Sokotai.
Even though I grew up here, it wasn't until I read the story of an excursion to the cities of King's Ruang that I appreciated how much of our history remains to be discovered.
I'm gonna Google it right now.
Cradle robber.
Google dictionary is just like, cradle robber.
Derogatory.
It's not that bad.
It says a person who marries or has a sexual relationship with a much younger person.
So it's like a cougar.
Or...
What's the other one?
What's the reverse?
Silver fox?
No, that's what you describe an old man.
Right?
I don't remember what the other is.
It's Matara.
No, Matara likes older men.
Everybody knows that.
I found a wonderful photograph taken by Prince Vajiravood in the university library.
Perhaps it is from when he was preparing to embark on his journey into the ruins of Sukhothai on January 4th, 1907.
January 4th?
That was just a couple days ago.
Is Minky a cougar?
No!
I'm a... I'm a... I'm a wolf.
I wonder how much his studies at Oxford inspired him to do this.
Tomorrow I shall make the river journey to the village.
I've brought gifts for Uncle Sunan and fried egg.
Is fried egg a person or...
Is that the gift?
It feels good to be back.
I wonder if the old tree house is still there.
Uncle fried egg.
Perhaps I could use it as a base for my field work.
Oh, are we gonna be searching for that?
For the tree house, I wonder.
Are you talking about...
An attack!
We can?
I
can't hear anything!
It's so loud.
How did they get me?
What's this?
Give me my bread!
How do I switch the gun?
Where are they?
I don't see where they are!
Why do you sound like you're inside?
Oh my God, hello.
Hello.
They're invisible!
The enemy are ghosts!
Oh
my God!
I think that's how they got me before.
OK
Hide!
Not a key?
No?
Storage key!
Don't go!
Oh my God!
I'm trying!
Oh, there are a lot of keys!
Key!
Oh my God, which key is it?
Wait, this is so awesome.
This is so funny.
Key?
Key!
This is so good!
Oh, I am?
Oh, there they are.
I'm covering you, Gina!
I don't know where they are.
I can't see anything.
It's too dark.
OK, let's go!
OK, open!
No, put it away!
Put it away!
Open!
I'm trying to open it!
There are too many keys, Gina!
I can't find the damn key!
Where are we going?
This way?
I'm running.
Why are they still attacking us anyway?
Oh my God!
Where did my friends go?
I'm lost!
Amiki is lost!
Friends!
Gina, how fast are...oh there they are.
There are my friends.
Everything is fine, baby!
I need an adult!
We should have known she was bad news from her eyepatch.
We can match though.
Now I'm bad news.
What's the difference between an archaeologist and a grave robber again?
The museum!
Museum!
Maybe.
Unfortunately.
Our boat is kind of loud though.
I am Pailin Chalat Phukalung.
Who are you?
My name is Ginetta Lombardi.
That sounds like...that is so much to write every time!
Goodness gracious!
I'm an archaeologist.
Another one.
I'm not like Voss.
But I know what he wants.
And I know how to stop him from getting it.
We're gonna kill him!
I will stop him!
One of them was sighted last night in their village.
What do you want me to do?
Save them!
What if we accidentally hit Sunan though?
If I start blasting.
Oh my god!
Tickle their feet.
Maybe give like...
Maybe give like a few more minutes.
For them to actually walk away, you know?
Stop yelling!
Oh my god, stop yelling please.
That guy on the bridge is like...
What's going on down there?
These guys are on our side, right?
I'm sure there are a lot of witnesses here.
Hello!
Save them!
Would you like some tea?
Yeah!
Yeah, me too.
Okay.
What if I go swimming?
I'll find you.
Yeah, literally.
What do I have to do anyway?
What do I have to do?
Why are you being so suspicious, Indy?
Cute!
Friendly cat.
As opposed to unfriendly cat.
Oh wow, we have the whole village we can go through.
Go to Sunan's hut.
Is that the hut?
Right there, I believe.
Okay, now we get to ransack the place.
Maybe I am just a grave robber.
Hello!
Okay, bye.
He's a traitor and a liar!
It implies that there is an enemy cat.
Nice view, huh?
What are you pondering here?
He seems to got a lot.
He's got a lot on his plate.
I think.
We'll leave him be.
Wow, someone's bed.
I'm gonna stomp all over it with my dirty feet.
I'm a menace to society.
Indiana Jones has no morals.
Maybe.
Rude!
Hello!
Good evening.
I think she's into me!
Maybe.
Are you getting sleepy?
Am I hypnotizing her?
What's happening?
She's amused.
We're not amused.
She's winning the staring contest.
Oh!
There's something not right here.
There's something not right in this town.
Oh, Jesus.
There's something not right going on here.
Oh, goodness.
You got anything for me to take?
No?
That's okay.
I'll find something.
I'll find something worth taking.
Bro, we work at 24-7.
I only have actual tears.
Oh, goodness.
Okay, I don't think there's much around here, is there?
I thought maybe like a...
Oh, maybe in here.
I was gonna say like maybe a...
Some sort of journal paper or something.
No?
Nothing?
Bethesda chasing game.
I had to refund due to crashing issues.
So here's part of what I would have paid for it.
No!
Wait, no, that sucks so much.
Wait, did you have it on PC or on Xbox?
Or is it...
Oh, gosh, where did that guy come from?
Is there anything other than Xbox?
I think I saw someone.
Fall?
No?
Nobody says hi to me in here.
You can't really explore this area until the morning.
Okay, thanks for letting me know.
We'll just go to the hut then.
Turn hut.
It's this one, right?
Over here?
Not this one.
Oh.
Nope, wrong family.
See, this is how you properly sleep.
So they can't properly sleep.
It's just everyone else is messed up.
Okay.
I want some tea.
Upright?
Well, with your eyes closed.
One question, Dr. Jones.
Yes?
What makes you any different from Boss?
I'm sexier.
You are both here to steal our cultural heritage.
No, I'm not here to steal anything.
But...
To ask for your permission.
I have the greatest respect for your culture and its history.
I even teach a course about the Siamese kingdom and its artifacts.
Well, you did.
This relic we're looking for has great power.
But to Boss, it is a weapon of war.
What?
He will do anything to get it.
He's not a traitor though.
He's just a liar and a killer.
Am I blocking the subtitles at all anyway?
A catch, eh?
The jar of terror!
It's the thing you hate and fear the most.
You have to put your hand in the jar and pull it out.
Face it with what you fear.
What?
A test of bravery.
The jar is cursed with magic.
You must prove yourself, Dr. Jones.
I can hear it slithering in there.
I can hear it.
Why does it always have to be snakes?
His face.
It's a worm!
It's pork intestines.
I thought it was a worm.
And he is not having it.
He's like, I'm going to murder these people.
Get pranked!
Where are the subtitles?
Huh?
Ok, ok.
We get instant translation.
Ok.
Clams!
Of clams.
The great clam.
From the clam.
The yeek?
What's a yak?
Oh, yak.
Yak!
Nice to meet you.
Everywhere is giants!
Yak!
Playing a prank on Indy proves that he can be humble.
A guy who can't laugh at himself can't be trusted.
Yak!
It struck me over the head.
I woke up in a secret temple.
The yak spoke to me in the old voice, in ancient language.
I begged the yak to see the blessed pearl.
The yak took pity on me.
It uncovered a chest shaped like a giant clam.
No way!
It really is the clam!
The great clam!
There was a pearl.
You said you know everything about our culture and history.
Why don't you tell us what the giant revealed to Lungsunan?
Hidden inside the chest was the blessed pearl.
I think anybody could have deduced that.
Carved in it was a word in a language so old no one could read it.
My guess is...
The blessed pearl...
looked something like this.
Wouldn't the pearl be round?
Take the small gears.
You'll understand.
The game doesn't tell you, but take the small gears.
Ok, I will.
Thank you.
Secret tunnel.
The music.
How's the audio by the way?
Secret tunnel baby!
It's good.
Thank you guys.
Sorry, I know it's a little bit late to ask.
Lungsunan trusts you, Dr. Jones.
So please, don't let him down.
I will arrange a boat for you.
But you will also need a breathing device to go through the tunnel.
Pay a visit to Tong Dang in the morning and he will assist you.
And he's got that creepy smile.
Muted the whole time.
Good morning, Mito!
I have to go get some medicine.
Some cough medicine.
Oh, a friendly cat!
No, I'm evil kitty.
What a cute kitty, I exclaimed as I pet the kitty.
Oh, let's get our map.
Map of the flooded ruins.
Oh, so glad that someone mapped that out for us.
Perfect.
Alright, so we're gonna go meet this guy.
Oh, no, we're going to join Gina.
All the way over there.
Can you sing the secret tunnel song?
It's from Avatar.
What,
like the last airbender avatar?
Sorry, I'm ruining your fishing.
Stop, stop, stop.
This is one way to meet with Gina.
Not the blue people avatar.
She changed!
I don't know the secret tunnel song.
If I had to guess how it went...
I would guess this.
Secret tunnel!
Wow, wow.
Where are your secrets?
And where do you go?
Secret tunnel!
Where are you now?
You're hidden below.
And you're so secret!
4Kids version?
Was it more raunchy?
Secret tunnel!
I hope you lead to boobs.
This isn't the 4Kids version, because it talks about boobs.
Secret tunnel!
Oh, I thought she was jamming on the guitar.
Ah, you got a gun.
I thought you were going to play to accompany my song.
My boat is ready?
Sorry.
Ok, the gun tour.
Hey Gina.
Do we have to go by boat?
Beautiful day for a walk, don't you think?
If you want to go for a walk, be my guest.
I'll be in the boat.
Ok.
I guess we're going.
Wait, what about...Wait, we didn't talk to the doctor.
Or the...I said doctor.
The guy that she said to get the breathing device.
Is she ok?
Maybe she...Oh the cat!
Sudden meow.
Gina.
Oh, she's wearing a white top though.
Is she ok?
You could say it's even a nice boat.
Take it easy.
Wait, what about...Hold on.
You good?
He missed the part where it's his problem.
You ok?
You're sweating girl.
You're sweating.
Hold on, I'm gonna...Oh, never mind.
Speak to Tong Tong.
Ok.
Alright, you're in perfectly safe hands, Gina.
She's like...Wait, where...Hold on.
You're in perfectly safe hands.
Gosh, this no person won't shut up about their teacher.
Hold on.
Oops, wrong button.
Where are they?
I think they're on the other side.
Oh,
he's right over there.
Ok, let's go.
Hello?
Are you the person I need to talk to?
Where is he?
Oh, over there.
Ok, you just chill right there, Gina.
Ok?
Might be easier if I walk.
Like she initially wanted.
You have the best what?
He's got the...
Grain.
He's got the best grain.
Why doesn't this connect?
Ok.
We might have to break into his house from under the house.
Ok, Gina.
How do we get in?
Gina, I think we're stuck.
Gina?
Gina, don't be alarmed.
But...
Ok, good.
I didn't flip the boat.
I was a little concerned for a second.
I'm working on it!
Today you're gonna learn how to slim, Gina.
Maybe I got...oh wait.
How do I get over there?
Ok, let's try from out here.
Little fish!
Oh, he's over there?
Ok.
We're gonna go find him.
He's not in here, is he?
Nope, ok, he's that way.
We're gonna find him, no worries.
I thought he was like in the village.
Is he in here?
Nope.
This looks like the entrance to a secret tunnel.
If I had to guess.
Oh, he's in here!
Ok.
He's
got books.
Yes.
Oh, how do I take photos again?
No!
I want to take a photo!
Tong Dang!
Look at his anime hair.
It's like sticking out.
Like anime.
Get a croc cap.
I wish.
Ok, it better be.
How much?
How much are we saying?
Say cheese!
Actually, we have some books that I haven't...
Let's see.
Fast Hands.
Let's unlock that.
Hello, Minto.
Hello!
Exploration.
That's just whatever stuff.
A guidebook to medicine.
Blah, blah, blah.
798!
I only have 213.
Give me all your money!
This is a stick up!
This is a stick up Tong Dang!
Tong Dang!
I'm not playing.
I'm not playing anymore.
Tong Dang, give me all your money!
And the breathing device.
He smiles in the face of adversity.
Oh my god!
How am I supposed to get that kind of money?
I see.
All the way over there.
Are you kidding me?
Why can't I rob Tong Dang?
That guy is literally...
That guy is scamming us.
I'm missing.
What's that?
The tree house!
Oh.
The kid who vanished.
Interesting.
This game takes place two years prior to Siam renamed to Thailand.
Also nice friendly price at negative 300% discount.
Man!
Wait, I'm guessing the red areas are bad zones, right?
Where we have to be sneaky, huh?
Probably.
Got my dill...
Pickle, right?
Pickle pizza?
Wait, what?
I'm gonna follow the map.
You think there's anything in there?
No, probably not.
Chicken and dill pickle.
What?
I've never heard of that before ever.
I just found out my dumbass somehow managed to make the dudes less at our university.
Are you proud of me, Mitsama?
So glad I switched my major to Japanese.
You are truly Japanese good!
Congratulations!
I see no dumbass.
What's that sparkling?
Is it in the spooky zone?
No.
Maybe?
What is this?
Sparkle, sparkle.
Sorry.
I'm docking, I'm docking.
Looks like a fast travel.
Nice.
Village.
What's in here?
No, no, no.
What do you mean see you soon?
You're coming with, right?
What's this?
Boat is docked.
Who did I tell that to?
Don't look away.
Oh, it's if you can call a boat.
What?
That's so cool.
Alright, onwards.
Sorry, wrong button.
We go around this little island and it's right on the other side.
Okey dokey.
Oh, sorry.
I'm not.
There is an invisible wall.
I don't know what I'm hitting.
Truly.
Maybe I park right here.
Park right here.
There.
Alright.
Am I on the right spot?
Close enough, maybe.
I think I'm on the right spot.
Okey, the game just saved.
Alright, bye Gina.
I just have to cross right over here.
It's not being monitored, is it?
Hmm.
Alright guys.
Time to remember how to fight.
I
don't see any guys.
Oh, I see guys!
But they don't see me.
And I see their money.
I'm taking all their money.
And I'm taking that.
Alright.
We got to get a lot of money, don't we?
Oh gosh, you guys.
I think I might...
That tie on the tent says get lost.
Thank you for translating.
I was curious about it too.
Oh, there is a couple guys.
That one too?
Maybe?
It says get lost.
I don't think they are wanted.
Oh, hello.
Vos' camp entrance.
I learned as well that the character Kokoro is pronounced minus tone.
Exactly the same as it is in Mandarin.
When read in Onyomi.
Like sheen?
Kitties, welcome to membership to Angu.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I think we have to take out the whole camp.
I'm not going to lie.
Do you think we could recruit those guys over there?
I'm in restricted area.
I'm scared.
What is behind this?
That guy is just chilling.
There is another guy there too.
I'm sneaky.
Stealth is a mere suggestion.
I don't know.
I don't know a good way to get in.
Maybe I shouldn't have gone through the front door.
Maybe going through the front door...
was a bad idea.
The game doesn't tell you, but there are radio towers that spawn stronger reinforcements if you don't break them.
The Sukhothai part is really annoying.
Oh, really?
Thank you.
You think I can shoot this guy?
What if I take them down with my...
gun?
He is looking literally right at me.
How do you survive that?
Run Endy!
Swim!
Swim Endy!
Dummies!
You can't find me!
I need to heal.
Bandage.
Use.
Like, immediately.
Is that a dog?
They
are like,
we don't care anymore.
Oh my god, there are so many guys.
There are so many guys!
Oh my god, there are so many guys!
Holy shit!
There was no way I could have done it you guys.
There was no way.
Oh my gosh, there were so many men.
Oh my god!
How do I want to do this?
Oh my god, there were so many guys.
This is gonna suck so bad.
You could have taken them.
We take hits a lot harder now, I noticed too.
They don't... It's like... I can't take the old one-two anymore.
I'm like one, one and a half.
Okay, let's go find another way in.
I'm leaving.
Why can't the guy just be... Why can't the guy give me a discount?
Wait, so are these... Oh, I think they are bad guys.
I think they are bad guys.
Okay.
Let's find another way in.
Gina, do you want to like... help?
I could use a second pair of hands.
Hello.
Oh, my boat is still running.
That's not good.
I'm gonna run out of... I'm gonna run out of everything.
What is she gonna do?
I don't know.
Seduce them.
Is this a dock?
Sorry.
I can't get close to it though.
It looks like a dock, but... Sorry.
Gina, I don't know where to go.
Okay, I'm just gonna go right here then.
Um...
Let's try... We can't go to the left side.
Let's try the right side.
We are sneaky.
We are sneaking around.
Okay.
Why are you judging me?
Why is he judging where I'm going?
Why I'm swimming or not?
Where is she?
Did she follow me?
I hear them.
I'm scared, you guys.
I'm scared.
There are so many guys.
I'm just like you.
I also whistle.
Maybe we can find any pennies that they dropped in between the things, you know?
What are these like tigers?
What do they mean?
I'm scoping out the place right now.
Currently I'm scoping.
Okay.
Might have to like use bottles and stuff to distract people.
So then we can take them out, you know?
I wish I could... Okay.
Oh, what's over here?
This looks like... This looks like an entrance.
Straight inside.
Oh my god.
I know what the white paint means, but I'm too afraid to go.
This actually looks like a great way to exit.
This looks like a great way to leave the camp.
This could be our escape route.
Okay.
The gamer paint.
Let's...
Oh my god, there's somebody right above me.
What do you guys think is the... Hey, I lost my...
Oh, I lost my... No, I lost the mallet!
I think it's in the water.
No!
I lost my mallet in the water.
Somewhere...
It's too stinky for me to tell.
Those are food for the local spirit.
Um, you're looking at a spirit right now!
What are you talking about?
It's obviously for me too.
Hello, I'm your local spirit.
Guys, I actually have no idea how to get in here.
I have no idea what would be the...
best way to get in.
That would be...
You know what?
Let's just go back.
If we die, we die.
We'll just go through and scope and see what happens.
So many plants and flowers.
Try the front door.
You know, I did try that.
What if I came in being like...
I offer...
I'm trying to see if I can find her.
I don't see it at all.
Sad.
I come offering...
Come on, Indy!
You can do it!
Indy!
ViviCortex for the gifted.
Nice.
Well, that...
That wasn't great.
That wasn't...
How do I even get up here though?
Because jumping didn't work.
Do I... Oh gosh, that scared me.
Are you coming down here?
No.
Was I crouch jumping?
I don't think I was... I didn't think I was crouched.
I'll try again though.
What?
You don't see anything!
Don't be like that mister.
Oh my God, he's camping.
Can you pull him?
I can try.
I can try to.
Let's see if he comes back.
Let me see if he comes here.
Hello?
Oh now you don't want to check.
Huh?
Now you're not curious?
They won't come down here.
Cowards!
How do I get back up there though?
Is the great question.
They're throwing things at me!
Rude!
That was a mistake.
There's even a bow in here.
There is a bow in here.
Good job.
Hello?
No, no.
They'll all line up one by one looking into the hole.
And that's when I'll blast them.
Look in!
Look!
I won't bother searching anymore.
How do I reload?
How do I reload actually?
R?
No, I don't...
Try to pull them with the whip into the water, they'll die instantly?
No way.
I wish I could.
Pull the trigger without aiming.
I don't believe you.
I don't believe you!
Press R1 when the gun is out.
No, it didn't work.
Ok, I'm gonna press the trigger.
Oh, it did work.
Elias, I'm sorry I didn't believe you.
I'm sorry I doubted you.
You were right though.
Is there anything I can throw?
Oh my god, he's got a big gun.
Come here!
I got his face!
Kind of.
Are you gonna come in?
Yeah, I am!
I am really scared!
I am!
I don't wanna come in!
Oh god, here we go.
Time to die!
If I die, it's me.
I don't think my whip did anything.
Why am I looking all smug for?
Wow, good thing we killed that guy.
We never have to worry about him again.
No, don't eat that!
Indy, the health.
What?
Why am I getting an achievement?
Celestial Delight?
Oh, I ate a starfruit.
When?
When did I eat that?
Perfect stealth boss.
Thanks.
Just now?
Yeah, but I didn't mean to.
Ok,
let's get this guy.
Is there anyone else in the room?
Which way is he coming?
Oh, there is two of them.
Where is my hat?
Where is my lucky hat?
Oh, there it is.
Why?
There is no reason to be so smug about this, Indy!
Where is your money?
Oh, I got a letter.
I'm not gonna collect... I'm just gonna...
Revolver bullets.
I'll take that.
Where is your money?
Give me all you got!
Fifteen?
That's it?
Oh gosh, guys, we're never gonna make it.
There's guns on the floor.
True!
Take that.
What's upstairs?
So glad the enemies in this game are a little dull.
Really?
Where are you?
Ok.
What's in here?
Royal Army kit.
Are you guys coming or...?
Nice!
Oh, now I have to use it as a...
Shit!
Where is my gun?
I mean my hat.
No,
I died!
Oh nice!
Wait...
Where the hell did you come from?
What the...
Oh my god.
No!
Where did you come from?
I don't want to carry the body.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Where did you come from?
Guys, this is the worst spot.
Wait, this is the worst spot for a save.
Are you kidding me?
Where's my hat?
No way.
I'm gonna die.
I'm dead.
No, we're gonna get spawn killed every time.
Oh my god.
No fucking way.
This sucks.
This sucks so bad.
All the guys that I just took out all respawned.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
Oh gosh.
This sucks.
This sucks so bad.
Punch him!
Oh there is a dog.
Oh my god.
No!
Where is my hat?
This is so bad.
No!
Fuck you!
Die!
Oh my god.
What do I do here?
What do I do?
Oh my god.
Maybe if I run upstairs.
Run!
Gun!
No!
This is the worst ever.
Please!
Okay.
Oh god.
I know there is a guy out here too though.
There is a guy out here too.
Oh god.
What am I supposed to do?
This is the worst.
This is the worst ever.
Oh god.
What the hell am I supposed to do?
Take the money.
It's nothing.
Stealth is perhaps not... Guys, I'm freaking out a little bit here.
Nothing.
I have to silently take him out I think.
Oh gosh.
If I stand up will they see me?
Just run and hit.
Get his ass.
There we go.
I got his ass.
What's this?
Oh that's his hat.
Do you have a lot of money?
Yeah you do.
Yeah you do baby.
But not enough still.
But still not enough.
Let's take this letter too.
Bribe letter.
Wait, what's in here?
Ok, this is good.
We just have to figure out what the code is.
We gotta figure out what the code is.
And then...and money.
I mean medicine.
What's your code?
Maybe it's in the bribe letter.
Maybe I should have read that.
I was just scared.
I was scared.
Ok guys, hold on.
You can't blame me.
Why do they just have skulls?
Ok, no one else seems to be coming up.
What's in the letter?
Bribe letter.
Inspect.
Gold.
Included in the gift package.
The code is...
Maybe it's 8008.
Can you loot the body?
Why is it highlighted?
I was kinda wondering that too.
Hello?
Code instructions!
5484.
Nice.
Big money!
So we are good now, right?
We are good now.
Buy the breathing device.
I guess we can just leave.
How much money do we have?
Oh wait...
2353!
Owie!
Shit.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm out of here.
No, no, no, no.
Where is the thing?
Here.
Yes!
Where did I leave the boat?
Hmm...
Gina?
Start the engines, Gina!
The engines are started!
You never turned them off, Indy!
Perfect.
And it's saved.
Oh yeah, baby!
We are the best to ever do it.
We are the best.
Let's get out of here, Gina!
Congrats, Robin Hood.
Yippee!
All it took was being re-zeroed for a second.
Invisible wall.
What is that?
Why is there a violin here?
If not for a romantic time.
What?
Strange.
Hold on, let's eat some bread real quick.
Take two.
No.
Take that.
No, don't take that.
Take the other bread.
I just ate two breads, did I not?
Take this.
Throw it here.
Take bread.
Why wouldn't it let me take it?
Don't look at me like that, Gina.
I give up.
Fake bread?
Impossible.
What's here?
What's this place?
This isn't a red zone.
What is this?
I see a shiny!
Wait, no, that's the shiny we went to before, right?
For the fast travel.
I guess I could have fast traveled to the...
Hot dog!
We went from Indy to MGS3 for a little bit.
Great job getting the gold.
Thanks!
It's a fight club!
Dang it.
New discovery.
Jungle bruiser pit.
Maybe we should just fast travel.
No, it's not that far away.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
It's like right there.
Jungle pit, baby.
More like jungle pits, am I right?
I wish I could go on a romantic boat ride with Mint Phantom in the jungle.
Is this romantic?
I'm stuck.
First rule about fight club.
We don't talk about fight club.
That looks like a fancier boat.
This looks miserable to be honest.
It's hot, there's bugs everywhere.
I don't know.
I wouldn't say this is romantic.
It's humid!
This guy is scamming me out of a bunch of money.
What is this?
Literature compendium.
Containing information on adventure books to be found.
What about this?
Oh, mysteries.
This game has so much going on.
Guess I gotta buy it.
You'll find the yak.
This guy actually sucks.
Look at him.
He looks so happy after robbing me blind.
Find the yim.
I saw some minkys in the tree over there.
That's a far away travel.
Trying to think of the best way to get there.
I guess just the way that we came, huh?
We'll have to go through...
Or the way that we went before, probably.
I'm worried about the red zones.
Oh yeah, we can fast travel to... Oh yeah, you're so right.
We can fast travel to the area.
What was that area?
The secret armory entrance, you say.
It's so secret they put it on the pole.
Not the village.
This one, maybe.
The sign is literally spoiling it.
So secret.
Ok.
We're not in restricted area yet.
They shouldn't get angry if we're just...
I'm just looking.
They can't get mad if I'm just looking.
If I'm just looking they can't get mad.
See?
This is why we look.
I'm just looking.
They can't be mad if I'm just looking.
Hey there.
Just having a little look.
He didn't even notice me.
I'm just looking.
See?
They're not mad because I'm just looking.
If I went inside they'd be upset.
I'm just looking.
Yeah, looking is not a crime.
Exactly.
But I took their bread.
That might have been a crime.
Oh look, our boat is here.
Fast travel is the best.
Can you tell smooches please?
Berry bug.
Berry bug?
Hi berry.
Do you want smooches?
These are for berry's ears only.
Everybody else mute.
Type muted after you've muted in the chat.
Say muted.
Okay, they're muted.
Off to find the yeek... I mean the yak.
The magical yak of the river.
Because, because, because, because...
We have to yak the river.
But we miss nothing, nothing.
Can we unmute?
If ever a yak there was a yak, the yak, the yak, the yak, the yak.
Because, because, because, because, because...
Because of the wonderful yak he was.
Oh, this way.
Turn Gina, turn.
We can't hear you.
When...
Yak.
She hates our nice boat.
She'll get used to it.
What was that splashing?
It's looking mighty jungly in here.
She thinks we could have walked this way.
She's crazy.
Yak.
Wait, we can just ask for smooches whenever we want?
No?
What are you talking about?
The yak.
This is our guy?
I think we can win him over.
Oh, his mouth is full of leaves.
That's how I like them.
Yak.
Sorry, since I practiced kissing on...
Shut up, Gina!
Shut up!
No, that's not what I meant.
That's not what I wanted.
You got lucky.
I think you should swim in the water.
You mentioned the underground water.
Oh, let's put this on.
I think you should swim in the water.
This is Gina.
Is this our tunnel?
How much air does this thing have?
I hope a lot.
Lift!
Gina, I swear to god.
I'm investigating the statue.
What are you talking about?
Hold on.
Uh oh.
Wait, I think it's running out of air.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh god!
It recovers the air, right?
Like it will recover, right?
How in the world can we hear her?
That's such a good question.
I'm investigating the statue like you said, Gina.
Gina!
Time to buy a new one.
No!
No, right?
No.
Oh see?
OK, OK.
Keep going.
I think if I go fast I'll be fine.
Is this an air pocket?
Yes?
OK, we got an...
That's a yuck.
That's a yuck in the water.
Nasty.
Die with no clothes.
Wait, are we talking to Gina from here?
We are talking to Gina from here.
That's so funny.
OK, go.
Go, Indigo.
Next air pocket?
Nice.
Through here?
OK, I see it going down.
Oh.
OK.
Alright.
Yikes in the water.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Air pocket?
Air pocket.
Fix the gear trains.
Metal gears.
Nevermind.
Yeah.
OK.
No, they are not metal gears.
Wooden gear.
OK.
I'll take a picture first.
No, photo.
Photo of the right gear train.
Wooden gear.
OK.
Come here, temples.
Weren't we here before with an archeologist a few months ago?
Don't say that.
So do I have to put them in the correct spot?
Oh gosh, there is... OK.
I see.
That one.
That looks good.
Oh, there is one more.
Nevermind, I lied.
Left gear train.
Oh no.
Pull.
No.
This one is too teeny tiny.
OK.
Why is Indy talking to himself?
It's just like the...
I want this one.
Are these the same size?
OK, hold on.
We put like that there.
Big boy.
Right there.
Big boy connects to other big boy.
And then... Oh no, wait, we need...
I think the teeny one is too teeny.
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, this one.
Yeah, it doesn't reach.
Reach.
Can this fit here?
No.
Are there more?
We need like a middle sized one.
Do you think they are in the water?
There is something on this side.
Oh, what's in here?
Wait a second.
A whole lot of nothing.
It needs both large.
Like if I take this guy...
Throw him away.
Take this one.
It doesn't fit though.
What in here?
I didn't see anything though.
I didn't see...
anything.
Unless...
Gamers don't look up.
Where?
That?
Is that a cog up there?
Oh wait, hold on.
I see the yellow tape.
The yellow paint.
I'm glad you knew.
Indy is like, yeah, I'm smarter than you.
Is this a...
This is not a mid-sized cog.
Share with the class, Indy.
Now I get our little cogs.
Take it out.
There.
Mid-sized.
Take it out.
There it is.
There we go.
Yippee!
Oh, there he goes.
Ok.
What did that do?
Alright, let's take all of our...
cogs back.
I'm just gonna place you right there.
Take you...
and just stick you away.
Ok.
So this one connects up here.
So this actually looks good.
Perhaps.
Wait, cogwheel?
Oh, no.
And then this one.
This might actually be it.
Hello?
Maybe the other way.
I actually can't tell if this teeny tiny thing is gonna work in that, but whatever.
You need to open the water first.
Make sure you also get the cog...
sogger.
No, if they're soggy then we...
Then they'll break.
How do I open the water?
Is it in here?
Use that?
Use that.
Use that thing.
Is it below?
Use it!
There we go.
Goodness gracious.
Is there anything else I missed in here?
I don't even know where I came from.
Again.
Down!
What?
I didn't see anything on the way in.
Doesn't seem like there's anything else in...
here that I noticed at least.
Do you want a hint?
Yeah.
I'll take a hint.
Wait.
Do I need to crawl through here?
Oh no.
I'll take a hint.
No hint.
Now you have to kiss it really sloppily.
Shut up!
It's in the room behind.
I have to go up?
Up.
Pay up.
One kiss, one hint.
No!
When did we ever agree to this?
You're scamming me just like that guy.
Hold on.
I'm just getting a vantage point from here.
There's really nothing home.
It's right there.
Why?
I can't see.
Where?
This thing?
Go back up.
What am I missing?
I noticed that earlier, but I didn't think it was a...
Ok.
I was like, oh, that looks like it's interactable, but it didn't give me a prompt, so I didn't know.
Yay!
Ok.
Oh no!
It didn't work!
Maybe I do need to put in the big one.
Right.
Oh no.
It's not gonna reach again though, is it?
I can try.
We have a problem at the source.
So it has to be one of these little guys here.
Or else it won't reach.
This is how I had it before, I think.
And this one, it turned all of them, but this one.
This one.
Big guy in the second slot.
Here?
I don't think the small one will reach here.
Yeah.
Sorry, my nose itches.
Oh, you mean like a big guy in the first slot instead of the two small guys?
Ok.
How many
cogwheels do I have?
I think three, right?
Yeah.
Ok, perfect.
There we go.
That should be it.
Yay!
Alright.
And...
Cutscene!
That is truly the best piece of paper.
Tina, you can come in now!
Jones!
Oh god, he's glitching out.
Tweet, tweet, tweet, tweet.
If only we were a bird, we would have been able to get in here so much easier.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god.
It's a monkey man.
Ah!
Gina.
Stay still.
Haha.
Snake.
We gotta call that guy that goes to the Everglades.
The guy that's looking for that 20 footer python.
Get to the pyramid.
What's the catch?
What's the catch here, huh?
What if I go into the water?
Alright, Gina.
I'm gonna go explore.
Ok.
It'll get ya.
Watch out, it'll get ya.
And it's one kill.
One hit kill, so...
Let's just...
Oh my gosh.
The controls on this are kinda whack.
I'm not gonna lie.
It's not me, you guys.
It's really the boat.
It's the game.
I try to turn right, but it'll make me turn left.
But it's not inverted controls.
So I don't understand why it does that.
Do you know how...
Wait.
Did you...
This boss fight was originally Resident Evil 4.
Stop!
Stop Resident Evil!
Ok, it's all the way over there.
So I'm just gonna floor it.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh.
Oh, I was just gonna, you know...
Look behind.
But I'm sure that works too.
The tower sticking out of the water.
Got it.
Well, we're right next to one, luckily.
So, um...
Oh, you're gonna make me do that, huh?
Ok.
Alright, I see it.
I see what we're doing here.
I see it.
Where is it, though?
Where's the snake?
Where's the slithery snake?
Where is he?
Me birthday today!
Want me to birthday thanks.
What?
Happy birth...
Oh, wait.
Happy birthday to you!
Ah!
Happy birthday, DFU Cloud!
Happy birthday to you!
Woo!
Happy birthday!
Alright.
I guess this is it.
Alright, Gina.
Don't say that!
Why would you say that, Gina?
What the hell is wrong with you?
And lift!
Oh my god.
Ok, let's go get more...
Let's go get more...
Oxygen.
Gina, why don't you do this, huh?
Watch out for the snake.
What are you being so cheeky for, huh?
It's not in here, though.
Oh god, I hear the snake.
That's right, she can't swim.
I
don't like that sound.
What was the point of opening that up, though?
Oh, damn it.
Oh my god.
Let me out, please.
I don't like this one.
Let's go try this tower instead.
Did I hear it?
Snake can't get you in the towers.
Yeah, yeah, I noticed that.
Oh!
There's something here, though.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?
Oh my god.
There's also...
Is that a tower or is that just plants?
Let's go check it out.
Just plant.
As soon as we get into the water, though, that thing starts tracking us.
So, like, what the hell am I supposed to do here?
Can I stop playing that BGM from...
That part of MGS2 in my head right now?
You know the one?
What, the one where we're escorting Emma?
I hate you, Gina.
Gina, you're lucky it's a hassle to take my gun out.
What the hell am I supposed to do here?
I just want to look.
I just want to look in there.
I don't see...
I can't really tell.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to get more air and then we're going to leave again.
You can enter the other towers underwater.
That sounds really scary.
I don't like this at all.
It did save, though.
Oh my god.
Is that a hole?
Right in front of me?
Right there?
Alright, I'm going to go for it.
Holy moly.
We made it.
It's just a snake.
A big, big snake.
Indy, you are completely valid for being afraid of this one.
I'm not going to lie.
This one is scary as hell.
That's the hole right there, I think.
Maybe it's my chance.
Go, Indy, go!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Uh-oh.
Wait, there's no water?
Oh god.
Okay, we just have to keep going.
Oh my god, no, no, no.
It looks like a ribcage.
It's kind of cool.
But I'm almost out of water.
I mean, air.
We are almost there!
No, no, Indy, don't die!
Indy, Indy, Indy, Indy.
Oh my gosh.
We did it, baby!
You got plenty of water, yeah.
Definitely not water I'm more concerned about.
Wait, what did we miss though?
Wait, what's in there?
A to ascend faster?
Thank you.
Did I miss a spot?
Did I go to the wrong place?
Or is this where I came from?
I don't know.
Okay, here we go.
Let's go.
Don't do that!
Entrance?
Where?
Here?
Oh my gosh.
We are fine.
We are not fine.
Oh my gosh.
What the hell am I supposed to do about this?
And I have... no.
What?
Wait, what just happened?
Okay, at least it's safe here.
Thank goodness.
Okay, this isn't a bad place to...
for it to...
save.
Okay, so now we are in the... thing.
And then we go to the side.
I'm going.
I see it!
I see it here.
Next.
Lift.
Oh gosh, please let there be an air pocket in here.
Ah!
Air pocket?
Air pocket.
Here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Holy moly.
Canoli.
Stromoli.
That was close.
I'll just add this to the collection.
Yippee!
We made it.
How is Gina gonna make it in here?
There's nothing down here, right?
No?
Okay.
Gamer?
GamerPaint?
Master, it is time and welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I missed the part where that was my problem.
Gamers jump down.
Nice.
I'm looking up though.
Just in case.
I don't see anything.
I think if I drop there I'll die.
Whip?
Oh, thank you guys.
I didn't see it.
Nice.
Gina is just out there with the massive anaconda.
No big deal, you know.
She'll survive.
Explore the pyramid.
So there's probably gonna be a giant in here too that we have to fight, right?
Since...
Yeah, I was gonna say.
It looks like the same.
Oh god, sorry, my nose.
Oh, I guess that works.
Jump up, Endy.
Endy, grab.
There we go.
Oh god, I was wondering what this was.
Oh my god, I thought it was a...
I thought it was like a blanket.
Snakeskin.
What's that over there?
Oh, what is that too?
Giant mushroom.
I've never
seen a mushroom that big.
So funny.
I don't wanna take a picture of that mushroom.
I think we can jump.
That didn't work.
See, I told you.
Look, there's three of them here.
I was just returning it to its rightful place.
I was just returning it.
Other people's failed attempts.
Do you put them in those holes?
Oh, shucks.
Oh no.
I think that wasn't it.
Skyraider, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Oh, look at that.
It's lit up.
It's lit up red.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I tried the mushroom!
Better angle?
Okay.
Maybe I need to go from the side.
I didn't think we were gonna make that.
I'll be honest.
Nice!
Oh look, they respawned.
They know we're dumb.
I think we should take one of these.
Honestly, I think we should take it for the snake.
Don't fall, Minky.
I won't...
I won't fall.
I won't fall!
We're fine.
She fell.
I fell again.
Use your arms, Minky.
Indiana Jones, you scare me.
Okay, there has to be a thing for my whip here, right?
Can you shoot the snake?
I don't know, actually.
I don't think there is a thing for my whip.
That's really unfortunate.
Didn't we get another grip book?
Oh, we did get a book, didn't we?
But I think it's for enemies.
Still unlock it though.
I'm gonna run for it.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Get up there, get up there, get up there, get up there!
How did I do that?
Tridents.
Okay, just end me.
Just kill me, snake.
Just kill me, snake!
There is no way I'm making it back.
Actually...
Oh no!
Why did I think that I would start right there?
That's fine.
It gives you quite a bit of time though before he attacks, I think.
So it's not so bad, maybe.
What sucks about running is I wish I could press down before I walk.
Because there is not a lot of space here.
If I push there, it's kind of tricky.
Okay, there we go.
Cement.
Flower!
Thanks for the super chat.
Thank you.
Run!
Jump!
Nice.
That won't be us.
Stupid idiot.
Mushroom.
Do I have to jump back to the other side again?
Okay, interesting.
Can I?
Can I hold this and run?
I wonder.
Oh wait, I think I can do it from here actually.
We made it!
Don't question it.
Oh shit!
Why did I do that?
Everything is A-OK.
Watch, the snake is going to come out for us.
While we are swinging.
And...go!
Go!
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't wish to know.
My heart rate.
Gimme!
Thanks for 7 months.
I don't like the snake near noise.
Me neither.
The clicking is so scary.
So freaky.
Oh my gosh.
I was afraid I wasn't going to make that.
But from here...
From here I'm not quite sure.
What do you guys think?
I've encountered many a snake but never one that uses echolocation.
This is Indiana Jones baby.
You gotta swim?
What to there you think?
I think that's the...
Yeah?
OK.
Cause I think that one is too high for me to climb from the water.
Oh gosh.
The light shows the way.
What's that sound?
Water drippy.
Drippy water.
Oh my god.
Uh...
What's here?
What is here Indy?
How do I get to there?
Oh the snake.
Is that a ledge?
This?
I'm trying to...
I think this one is too far for me to reach.
Can I climb up on to here?
I don't think that's white gamer paint is it?
I think that's just a...
Can you whip from here?
No.
It would say RB if you could.
Alright I'll try the gamer paint.
Oh it is ledge.
Good thing we got our nifty grip up.
Uh...
From here RB.
And...
Nice.
Why is the music escalating?
Why is it getting a little more intense?
It's making the water ripple!
That's so awesome!
That's such a cool visual.
I see it.
Hmm...
I'm looking around.
Oh good it just saved.
Oh good it just saved!
Yippee!
Ok we are safe.
In case anything happens to me.
Do I go to the middle?
I think I have to go to that over there right?
But I want to go look over there.
It looks so cool.
Ok.
Plan B.
What?
Oh god!
I'm ready to fist it!
Gotcha!
Where did the other one go?
Can more spawn please?
Wait, I need more...
I might have to use my gun.
No, my gun!
Oh up?
Oh thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Ok, let's look up.
Damn it!
What the hell?
But it was red I swear.
More?
Oh come on!
Turn into Sephiroth scene for a second.
That should have hit.
I'm
out of things though now.
For real.
I'm out of ones.
Oh no, no, no.
Just kidding.
Oh please, please, please, please.
Please grab!
Ouch!
Oh god.
Bastard.
Oh that hit hard.
Yippee!
We did it.
Victory jump!
Ok, nice.
The tower.
Where did it go anyway?
Another pitchfork.
Yes, Indy, I would like for you to climb up that.
Ok, nevermind.
This one works too.
Dang it, I need to go down that.
Alright.
Shot!
I
can't!
Oh game.
If it works, it works.
Right baby?
Can we grab onto this?
Oh we can.
Nice.
Gina is just out there twiddling her thumbs I guess.
Oh my god!
Indy no!
You gamed too hard!
Oh my god.
Do I have to go all the way back?
Do it again?
Where am I?
Wait, where am I actually?
Oh ok, there it is.
Ok.
Wait.
There we go.
Indy had enough.
So did I!
I don't know where exactly we are going.
Around the ledge perhaps?
Oh well.
Yes.
We can drop down here.
Drop.
Nice.
Not good.
Wait, wait but...
What's over there?
Why does it...
Why is it...
It looks like I can go over there though.
Geronimo!
Welcome to Mamba Shop!
Thank you!
Oh I see the Shrine of Ashura.
I see it, I see it.
Oh I thought that was a snake.
Hit!
But hold on, let's check this out first.
Because that looks like it's going to lead to the exit.
What's up here?
Secret.
What is that?
This looks important.
Take a picture Indy!
No?
Don't take a picture Indy.
Who cares?
Now I don't know where to go.
Now I'm not quite sure.
Because that one also leads up.
So maybe we go look in the tunnel first then.
Let's go in here first.
They all have gamer paint!
When there's exploring in the Explorer's Game.
That's not the issue I have.
Is that this game has been quite...
I don't want to say quite linear, but it's been...
In terms of exploration, it's great.
But when it comes to areas like these, it's pretty linear.
When it's open world stuff, obviously it's nice and open world.
But...
Maybe there's an Among Us.
Where are we?
It's more so that I don't like missing out on stuff.
So I'm like, if we had gone the other way, what...
What would have been?
It's just a hole, so let's crawl through here.
We're back out here.
Oh, we're all the way up here now.
Interesting.
More snake skin.
Nice.
Good job, Indy.
Just trust your instincts.
As a gamer.
Okay, Indy.
Nice and shimmy.
Shimmy, shimmy, shimmy.
The music's getting a little funny.
What was that sound?
Sounded like a hiss.
Like a snake.
Oh, we're so close to this though.
Something tells me that the giant snake we saw was actually a baby.
Don't say that!
Oh my god.
I jumped, but it didn't register.
That scared the hell out of me.
That's sick.
Look, that's exactly how that guy died.
Or, that's what they want you to think.
They planted that afterwards.
Died a badass.
I don't know about that.
He got hit.
I don't know about badass.
Badass wouldn't have died.
Both paths lead to the same place?
Really?
Is that the way we would have gone, I suppose?
Wait, I want to go in there though.
Oh, we are.
Oh, I was asking.
Oh, I don't know.
I have no idea.
The other way was just a collectible.
No!
We missed the collectible.
Why did I do that?
Sorry, my finger slips.
My finger slips when I do that sometimes.
Because I grip the controller really hard when I'm pressing the L2 or L3 I mean, or whatever it's called.
L2?
So my fingers accidentally sometimes hit it.
You've been here the whole time?
She's been calling here the whole time.
I'm dead!
You liar, Indiana Jones!
You did not kill it!
You are a liar!
What's down here?
Oh my gosh.
Shut up, Gina.
Come on.
Get ready.
Yeah, no, he totally killed it.
Curse of Ra.
So this is what we are trying to open, right?
Let's see.
What's this over here?
Seems like a knob to open the gate.
Just kidding.
Oh wait, there is one right there.
What did I just hear?
Ok, you grab that one and I grab...
That's what I was saying.
Ok.
And go!
I'm sequence breaking.
I'm too smart for the game.
Game room?
We are gaming!
We are gaming for real.
Win the game?
Look at the little people.
Little people?
Big people.
What's this?
Camera?
Did I get a camera thing?
I don't think so.
I didn't get a camera prompt.
I like how she's like, it looks like it's guarding something.
Oh, I guess it actually does.
Nevermind.
I doubted you, Gina.
Alright, what's the game?
Uh...
I can only hold one at a time.
What the hell is this?
Win the game.
Hold on.
Ok, hold on.
There's gotta be a clue for this somewhere.
Um...
This is whack-a-mole.
I thought it was gonna be like you take it out and you try not to...
You know like the ones where you pull out the sword?
Oh wait, no, you stick in the sword.
And then the pirate pops out.
Nope, just play.
Oh, these pop out.
Ok...
I just played the game by the way, chat.
You just lost the game.
That's quite a cough you got there, Mr. Morgan.
Do I make them... What's the objective though?
Do I make them all face the same way or is it...
I can't really tell.
Gina?
Did you just walk through that wall?
What?
What was the name again?
Blackbeard.
Oh, I can't read the kanji.
I can't read the kanji.
What, what, what, what, kanji, kanji, kanji, kanji, paper.
Ah, ok.
What's the objective?
Gina's moonwalking.
Are they all supposed to be in or out?
Are we inies or are we outies?
Thank you.
That hat doesn't open.
Ok, now we have more game pieces to work with.
So wherever they face... Gina move!
So whichever way they face... Wait, these only have... Ok, so these have one little dot.
And these have two dots.
These have two dots.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
And... here.
Oh, that's the wrong one.
Just kidding.
You, there we go, you.
I figured out your code!
Code!
Easy peasy.
Tsukutai!
Stone.
He's always smiling.
Oh!
Genius ghost mint.
He's smart.
Oh, you didn't like the picture taken?
What does that mean?
The entrance is opening, but...
At least we got the picture.
What's happening?
Are they all gonna turn?
Oh no, indeed.
Indeed.
Am I gonna have to punch you again?
Oh my... Gina!
Gina!
I don't think that helped.
It helped.
Gina.
Run!
She's just watching.
We lost our hat!
Oh.
Oh come on, indeed.
You could've let go.
It wasn't that far of a fall.
Watch, the snake's gonna be in here too.
Oh my god.
We're gonna have to fight you and the snake at the same time, aren't we?
Oh my god, no.
Oh god.
Ah!
Press A.
Thanks for the tutorial, game.
Oh god, oh god.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die!
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
That's OK.
It's OK because I...
Oh my god, this is where we start?
Wait!
Oh my god!
Please, I wanna heal!
This way to the...
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm trying to dodge.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
OK, OK.
Alright.
Ouch!
How is his swing so big?
Good lord!
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
No!
I can't dodge because it uses stamina.
When he does that...
Oh gosh.
Or maybe it doesn't.
Oh it does, it does, it does.
I'm gathering stamina again.
I'm gaining my stamina back.
I'm gaining my... No I'm not gaining my stamina.
What the fuck?
Why am I not gaining my stamina back?
How do I get out of fight mode?
OK,
OK.
Nice, nice.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Am
I supposed to do this?
Or is this the cutscene?
I can't tell.
R3!
Mirror of the snake, baby!
Get hugged!
No, nothing.
It's a depression.
Stop hugging!
School boys!
He's trying to kill me!
So true.
Speak some sense into the sky.
I must protect the words.
I must atone for my ancestors.
For god's sake!
Who cares?
You are both stuck in the past.
And right now there is a great evil spreading throughout the world.
And we can choose to fight against it or each other.
He looks so tired.
Great distraction!
I meant what I said.
Let's get out of here.
This place gives me the gibbie gibbies.
The gibbie gibbies!
You got him out of the water though, right?
That guy fell face first into the water.
Like you...
You like turned him over though, right?
Anyway...
He's too tall to drown.
Fair, fair, fair.
Alright, let's go home.
Yeah, we just walk it off.
Just everybody do a little stretch.
Oh, this is where we came in from.
That's so exciting.
Gina did absolutely nothing.
She didn't have to help at all.
Wait, so why are we leaving?
Where is it?
I was gonna say, because like...
A study in fear.
Because didn't we say that the map was gonna help us find the stone in there?
But I guess not.
I guess it's not inside.
What else we got?
Study in fear.
Might be worth stopping by Pailin before talking to Sunan.
No one has better insight into the fascist activity in the area than she does.
And then the kid who vanished.
We gotta find the tree house.
I'm kinda curious about this one.
Let's track that one.
Because we found the tree house before.
Oh, wrong way.
Wait, what's over here actually?
Among us?
Oh, we can take a photo.
That's it?
Indy is drowning.
I missed the part where that's my problem.
Romantic.
Now it's a romantic boat ride.
Look at her, you know you do.
It's possible she wants you to.
It's just one thing to ask her.
It don't take a word, not a single word.
Thanks for the 5 gifted subs.
Memberships.
I know how to drive this thing.
Look like the boy is too shy.
He's gonna kiss the girl.
Ain't that sad?
It's such a shame.
Too bad you're gonna miss the girl.
Wait, we didn't get this one before.
What is this?
Sorry.
She gets out of the boat so fast.
Where are we?
It
doesn't say restricted.
Tiger.
Another one.
What is this place?
Things I can steal.
That's actually... Nope, that's not what I wanted to do.
Yeah, maybe heal.
That's exactly what I was gonna do.
Jump, jump, jump, jump.
And heal.
We're just looking.
And stamina, stamina, stamina.
That's not what I meant to do.
Stamina.
These are heals, right?
Yeah, bandage.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I love these little stock areas.
You think they'll get mad at me?
I mean, maybe they shouldn't leave their food around.
The gun?
I don't think I need it right now, right?
I mean, this isn't a restricted area.
Right?
Hold on.
I'm gonna go to where they'll save for me.
I think it saves down here.
Hello.
Okay, bye.
I'm just exploring a little bit.
I'm just gonna waltz on in.
If you have the gusto...
If you have the gusto, they won't question it, you know?
They'll be like, this guy is meant to be here.
We just gotta go in with confidence.
We just gotta be like...
We just gotta be like, yeah, I'm meant to be here.
Act like you belong there.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
I belong here.
Oh, I don't belong here.
I don't belong here.
Gina, start the boat!
Gina!
Gina, Gina, start the boat.
Gina, we gotta get out of here, Gina.
I messed up.
Gina, I thought it was okay here.
We gotta fast travel.
Oh no.
Whose house?
Where can we go?
Everywhere is locked.
Gina, start the boat.
Oh my!
See you later, suckers!
Stupid!
Where are we?
Okay, we gotta go this way, I think.
Take a picture of what?
Capsize barges.
Not us.
What
the?
Gina, are you okay?
You good girl?
Hold on, spider monkey.
Hold on tight, spider monkey.
Did we get this one?
No, we didn't get this one either.
Did this technically dock the boat?
I guess so.
Now we can fast travel, huh?
What is this place?
Here is the radio.
Is that what makes it so that I can come back?
Boat is docked.
Tiger!
I don't think I'm welcome here.
I have a sneaking suspicion.
That I'm not welcome here.
The boat started to annoy the heck out of me.
Really?
So far I'm not hating it so much, but...
You know, I can understand.
It's definitely probably not the most exciting of the places we've been and things we've done.
Nate, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Okay, so we're gonna pass you.
This is the guy that we got the breathing thing from.
I guess we could have fast traveled to his place, huh?
Now that I think about it.
I'm sorry guys, I'm so stupid.
It's like right in here.
Treehouse.
Is that gamer paint?
I swear though, I think they're gonna have me wanting to...
They're like, this kid's gone missing.
I think they're gonna want me to try and find him.
And he's gonna be locked in like some place.
I don't think that's gamer paint.
And it's gonna be in like one of those little campgrounds.
I just don't feel...
Where?
Oh, up there.
I'm paranoid of the water now.
Random doll.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
The frog for death.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Boat is docked?
Oh.
Cool!
Nice.
Thanks Gina.
I'm not
quite sure.
Item limit.
Oh, the repair box.
Gina's just strolling on in though.
Maybe we're fine.
So I gotta go up there?
Maybe we have to go around.
And she's gone.
Gina.
Gina, I need you to have like a little bit more...
Of like... Oh, there you are.
Okay.
She has like no... What's the word when you like don't care...
If you live or die?
Self-preservation?
Maybe?
Yeah, she has no sense of danger at all.
Okay.
The treehouse just sounded so enticing.
Of like a side mission, you know?
She's like a dodo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's this?
Another recipe.
Remember to eat my dear nephew.
Your mind needs food to function.
This is how you prepare fish cakes.
Alright, if anybody wants to make fish cakes.
How is my stamina looking?
Cool.
Eat your fish cakes.
Pull!
Yeah, Gina!
It won't help if you clip out of existence, Gina.
No!
You need to heal.
So why is it all boarded up anyway?
Oh no!
What is he going to do with the kids?
Well, you know.
That's on... We'll see.
We'll see.
If he is in one of those little camps...
He got himself into the mess, so...
Is it really my job to get it back?
This picture of him with his uncle.
Can we go up?
Oh, you're right.
Let's check.
I missed the part where that's in the problem.
Exactly.
Oh, hidden map.
If my theory is correct, there is another older temple buried beneath Wat Si Sawai.
Perhaps it was a test of courage for Khmer warriors.
And what if the old mechanisms still work?
I'm no warrior, but with all I learned at the university in Krung Thep...
I think I can figure out how some old traps work.
I've noted the possible location on the map.
Treehouse, ruins...
Mandapa...
I wonder what the Italian soldiers are doing near the treehouse.
I should ask them what they want.
Mmm, corn.
Ok, Gina.
She's like, you know when kids are trying to...
When they're like, mom, look what I can do.
I want to show you a cool trick.
And they like, it's just them flailing in the water or something.
Ok, now she's floating.
Ok, Gina.
Oh my god, what do you mean not far from here?
Indeed, that's pretty far.
Hold on tight, spider monkey.
For real.
Witch!
You've been here the whole time!
Girl, what are you saying?
I love how janky this game is, I'm not gonna lie.
It's just endless entertainment for me.
It's some of my favorite things is when a game is...
I know not everybody thinks that way.
They're just like, I paid good money and the game is...
It's dumb, but I just...
Yeah, it's playable.
It's playable, exactly.
What the hell was that?
What was that?
Hello?
You think we're welcome here?
Sorry.
Nah, let's just go to our destination.
Sorry, I'm constantly needing to check.
These rivers kind of confuse me.
Yeah, up and... Wait, is it up and around or do we go down this way?
Actually, I can't tell.
I can't tell if that's a river through there.
I can't tell.
Oh wait, but there's a shiny there.
Where they built by the people of Siam?
Looks like we can walk.
Walk this way!
Nice.
I see, I see.
What is this?
Delivery note.
I've secured a crate of grappa.
As promised, tell the men we will have a get together after the shift is over.
I have planned some fun and games too.
It's important to keep morale up at times like this.
Fun and games!
Oh, that's a guy.
I don't really want to be sneaking around.
I'm not gonna lie.
I guess we don't have to sneak.
I guess if we do that, we don't have to sneak even a little bit.
Oh, this way.
Alright little guy, where is our nephew?
Ok, we are almost there.
Through here.
What's this?
Oh gosh, I have to find this kid.
Oh, he's a little dot.
Oh, enter the temple.
Just kidding.
He's not a little dot.
Oh, it does look like corn, doesn't it?
I think this guy is gonna notice us.
Take a picture of what's this?
Hawaii?
Nice.
Actually, this one is better.
I see at least five guys.
Every mission is a stealth mission if nobody is alive to report that they saw you.
That's what I'm saying.
I did see the whip thing.
Oh my gosh, Gina, you scared the hell out of me.
I saw the whip thing, but I think it was just to go up.
I don't know if there was anything up there.
What's up here?
Gina, let's check this area out first.
There's more mallets too.
Perfect.
I think I can climb up this once the going gets tough.
There's three guys here.
I think I can take them down with the mallets.
Alright.
Oh, never mind.
Picture time.
Of this guy.
Paint... No, just kidding.
We don't care about him at all.
What am I painting message?
Oh!
2480!
What do you mean new mystery?
Path of Tigers!
Alright.
Oh, Gina.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna sneak up and take him out.
He's hungry.
He won't notice.
Sweet dreams.
Sweet dreams!
Oh,
Gina, don't do that.
What, Gina?
Gina?
Stop blocking!
Feeling woozy?
Yeah?
That's right.
No, I don't want the body.
I want your weapon.
Nice!
Do you know with the distraction they were like...
Woman!
Good job, everybody.
Nice!
Mommy!
Anyone else around here?
Or did they all come running?
Oh, definitely more guys.
God,
that guy can take a hit.
Yeah, Gina.
Can't be seen!
Get down!
Anything in this?
No.
Good thing they didn't notice anything.
I hear even more guys.
I wish I had another...
I wish I had another sledgehammer.
Movies and video games have...
Really, wait...
Really have people way too into their job.
Like if I saw a dude with a sledgehammer attack my co-workers, I'm leaving.
Right!
It's true!
Definitely one of those like...
I don't think I get paid enough for this kind of moment.
Oh, I think he's down.
Damn.
What are you doing, Gina?
There we go.
Lights out, fella!
Wait, is there another person?
No.
What was I going to do?
I was going to eat some fruit.
And I'm going to steal all their fruit.
Where the hell are you going, Gina?
Just closed on buying a place.
I'm a homeowner now.
Can you bless it so it's not haunted?
Oh...
What?
Like you mean buy a different ghost, right?
You would want me to haunt your home, right?
Obviously.
Congrats, Cat Daddy!
You mean like buy a different ghost that's not...
Minto, though.
I get it, I get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
Obviously.
Yeah, obviously.
Gina's off having her own adventures again.
Where did she go?
No ghosts at all.
But...
That means you don't want me...
You don't want me in your house...
Haunting your house and eating your food.
And you don't...
You don't want me moving your cups and drawers at night.
And you don't want me...
You don't want me...
You know, pulling off your blanket.
Or knocking on your doors.
I missed the part where that's my problem.
No!
Maybe I shouldn't have run in.
Maybe I should have taken the...
Maybe I should have taken the ladder.
Oops.
Oopsie.
You think there's gonna be guys in here?
Oh, a book.
Handyman.
Increases durability of melee weapons.
That's huge.
And... I thought that was a hand.
Oh, it is a hand.
Just kidding.
Iron grip.
More iron grip.
I never really clinch the enemies anyway, but you know.
Handyman.
I leave all my drawers and cabinets open.
I also keep all interior doors closed and have no mirrors.
We need a... We need a weapon.
We need a melee weapon.
Maybe this will work.
Just kidding.
That didn't work.
Maybe a rite of passage for Khmer warriors.
Wait.
That's not one either.
Dang.
Yeah, your name is Binary Ghost.
Are you not a ghost?
We found them.
You're in here?
I do.
Very good English.
I'm Gina.
This is Indiana Jones.
Sunan sent us to help you.
Oh, thank you.
The foreign soldier forced me to show them what I found.
Now I'm trapped in here.
That's so sad.
It's alright.
We'll find a way to reach you.
Yeah.
Let's go, Jones.
Stay out of trouble, kid.
I think we could probably move it.
I think we can move the rocks, Gina.
Be careful.
I think we are strong.
OK, we need...
Sorry.
We need a little...
Little knob.
Oh wait!
This looks like we could turn it.
No?
Just kidding.
We need the car.
That's what I said!
Do it!
Oh.
OK.
No.
You do that handle.
I'll get the closer handle.
This one.
Alright, ready?
OK.
Pipe segment.
What the hell is that?
OK.
I don't...Are we going down?
I don't really like...I don't like...
Oh wait for Gina.
Oh sorry.
Oh god!
OK.
Let's go.
Where?
Where the hell are you?
I hear him, but I don't see him at all.
Oh there he is.
Jump!
Just jump down.
Jump down.
You'll make it.
We have to find a way to lift the platform.
Got it.
Oh my goodness.
This place is kind of huge.
OK.
Big gears.
Can I go up here?
Can I not go up here?
OK.
I'm just getting lost at this point.
It looks like I can go up there though.
I nearly got soft locked here.
Oh you see?
Don't scare me.
It's impossible to get through.
At least for now.
Oh gosh.
There is a lot going on here.
OK.
I'm just going to keep walking around.
The only Indiana Jones movie I ever watched was the Crystal Skull.
Wow.
Tell me you don't watch membership streams without telling me you don't watch them.
I'm just kidding.
Hot dog gacha.
There is?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
Gina?
Where?
Oh wait.
Here?
Why is it saving?
Minky?
Gina's backseating actually helps for once.
Oh my gosh.
Are you OK over there?
Over there?
Oh god.
I think I just panic jumped.
I didn't know what to expect.
OK.
Wait.
Do I have to go to the other side?
Yes.
OK.
It's fine.
Did she make it?
Oh she did.
Oh OK.
I guess I'm the only fat ass here.
Wow.
This is so messed up.
Yes, but also...shouldn't it be...going...wait.
Hold on.
If we turn this...
OK.
But what about this one?
This is the one to...
Do something.
Hold on.
I see the picture thing.
Before I forget.
Before I forget...oh giant cog wheels.
Oh wait for Gina.
OK.
Gina?
I'm waiting for you.
OK.
Here we go.
What are we doing?
Oh we're just moving it?
OK.
That's it?
And then...
When we're ready for this one, we'll do it.
Now,
we take you.
Drop.
Do I have to turn it off?
No.
OK.
It doesn't matter.
Take that.
Put you here.
Facing east.
And put you...facing...I don't know actually.
No.
Place you facing west.
And pull!
Let's try this.
OK!
Pull!
One moment.
There we go.
OK.
Very good.
Oh god.
That'll kill you.
Gina where did you go?
I think she's dead now everybody.
Very good.
I think we climb up there.
And climb.
She got crushed.
Where are you?
Oh.
You're over there.
You didn't even come through.
You coward Gina.
Stupid Gina.
Stupid coward.
I hate the way it pushes me back.
I'm fine!
He has Indy's angry voice down so well.
Do you think I can make this?
I'm too good.
Where was the one that allowed my...
Nice.
OK.
I was going to say this isn't getting closer to us is it?
We can't crawl underneath this can we?
Oh we can.
Perfect.
Troy Baker sounds more like Harrison Ford than Harrison Ford.
He's just old now.
It's not his fault.
He's an old man.
Oh I thought...what is this?
Oh.
Interesting.
Yes!
Oh my God!
I can't believe...at least we're not actually on fire.
It reminds me of when you accidentally set yourself...or maybe not accidentally...
but when you set yourself on fire in Red Dead Redemption and then in the cutscenes...
just like their skin is melting off.
Oh my God.
That was so stupid.
Alright Gina.
You need help?
She's got this.
I can't...that was so silly.
So silly!
Silly!
There's no where for my...
for my thingy.
My whip.
Oh we just activated the trap.
Don't touch that Gina.
Oh just kidding.
Maybe it's fine actually.
Oh.
Okay.
I guess it's fine.
Hold on.
I want to check up here real quick.
I'm taking your bread.
Milk tea bread sounds amazing.
I would like to eat that.
Sounds so good.
I thought we were...oh pipe puzzle big!
I thought we were in the main room.
Bridge with a statue.
Okay.
I see one up there.
Alright.
Let's find all the pipe pieces.
Put them all together.
I'm Indiana Jones in the circle.
Where are you?
He's gonna activate the traps or something.
Or we're gonna activate the traps.
Something's gonna...the traps are gonna get activated.
We know this.
Somehow.
I'm so glad that's durable.
Cody, I read that as circle of mid at first.
I was like oh okay.
Now I understand.
Circle of mid.
Okay,
so we have two.
Is that it?
Is that it for up here?
I guess so.
What the hell is that?
Ancient spear.
What's down here?
Don't catch yourself on fire this time now, Indy.
Okay.
I'm just gonna steal this.
Well, actually, yeah.
I'm gonna steal it.
Okay.
Traps in this game?
Nonsense.
That'd be your stupid silly.
Okay, let's go to the other side too.
Oh, maybe that's what we need to open up.
My oshi made mid phantom.
Where does the water come from?
Where is the water?
Where do we get the water?
Oh, look at that.
Where?
Near the entrance.
Right.
I need to know which way they are flowing first though.
Right?
Like I can't just put in pipes and not know anything.
I don't see a...
Even a place to put the little staff that we got.
I don't see a place for it.
Follow the water sound.
This one?
The one that leads to nowhere.
Oh, I see it.
Good thing this is sturdy.
My god.
Or I'm assuming this is it.
Okay.
Alrighty.
Cool.
So water goes down.
Go to here.
We need to go to...
Here?
Please.
Please!
Ah...
Okay.
Yes, you can go there.
And then you...
You can go here.
Ah, nope.
Oh, oops.
The wrong one.
You can go here.
Okay, we got it open.
Alright.
Yep.
Oh, it's this thing again.
Run!
Steal.
I'm trapped.
Okay.
And...
Go!
Now, which one are we trying to open now?
Trying to open...
Maybe like the three of these, I imagine.
That's probably the case.
So...
We have to direct this to...
Oh no!
Uh-oh.
Okay, we might have to finish this puzzle and then call it a day for now.
Maybe I'll finish this puzzle and then call it a day.
So this one...
Needs to go...
Not here.
Oh, here.
Through here.
Right.
And forward.
Do we have a power cable?
Probably somewhere.
Actually...
Oh wait, actually this one might be long enough.
Hold on.
Unplug it from my Switch.
Yeah.
Mii Phantom, you need a controller for this game.
I know.
Yeah, I know.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
So we need this area.
Maybe I can drop here.
Like so.
Okay.
Can this one be...
I only have curvy ones left.
What did I do with my straight one?
Oh, I had it... What did I do with the straight one?
I can't remember.
Oh yeah, now it's not going to this one.
Okay, hold on.
I wish I could zoom out and see this from a bird's eye view.
I guess I can go up here and look at it.
Let's try that.
Let's see, let's see, let's see.
Okay, here we go.
So we needed to go...
It
has to go through this one.
Like it absolutely has to go through this one.
100%.
I got stuck on this puzzle for way too long.
Oh, is Doki here?
Hi!
Oh, how was Bellatro?
Did Doki like it?
This one, we kind of ignore this.
Actually, I don't even think we can place anything on this one.
She did one run and went to play Marble Run.
No way.
She got really lucky number 7.
I don't know anything about Bellatro, so that means nothing to me.
Let's see.
I'm currently trying to use my brain.
I have to use my brain.
How am I supposed to...
3...
Technically, we can have this one curve into here, I think.
I think.
So we'll have that curve into there.
Or, I mean, right?
Wait.
I'm just going to place that, since I believe that to be correct.
No.
No!
There we go.
OK.
How do I hot dog?
Also, distraction successful.
It's a gotcha.
The hot dog is a gotcha.
I feel like I'm missing a pipe, right?
But he said this is all I got.
This is all I need.
Maybe this one is not straight here.
This one is straight here.
Oh, OK.
And then, somehow...
Let's see, there's no water going to...
There's no water going to this one at all, which makes it difficult.
Thanks for that.
Hot dog!
What the?
What's pushing me?
What was pushing me?
That was weird.
Water doesn't have to come from the start?
There's other places the water can come from?
Or...
There's no...
way to direct water into...
to the left.
Can I get a feel better soon breed?
I just got skinned.
Cancel an event such as artist alias.
But 2K, oh no!
No breed!
Get better soon!
Feel better beam!
Wait a second.
If I take this...
and make it go straight...
Nope.
Straight.
And then we T here.
Like that.
Oh, wait.
No, wait.
Because only...to get to the middle is only this path.
So...
I don't know!
If it's like...
But even still this wouldn't work.
Because then it just go...
Need to make sure the rotation is right.
Is there anything else in here that I missed?
I'm checking.
I'm checking, I'm checking, I'm checking.
I don't see anything.
I don't see anything that I missed.
No.
Sending water left and right but not the center?
Oh yeah, I guess if we send it here...
But from here...
We would need another T.
You know what I mean?
Because like...
If I did this...
And had it going both ways...
And then this would be here.
Like that.
So I have the tube but not the middle, but...
If I have it...
The key is that there is like so many pipes on this side.
To where the water can be redirected to.
Wait!
I had it!
I didn't realize it would come in through here.
Yippee!
We brained, we brained, we brained.
Alright, go on.
Why don't we ever see the monkeys?
Oh that's a bird.
Nevermind.
Can I take a picture of the bird?
No!
Bird got food.
I'm gonna eat it's...
Shit fruit.
You know how like birds will eat the fruit...
And they poop it out.
And then it grows more trees.
That's gonna be me.
Oh, please go the same way.
Okay.
Gina?
Gina, you good?
Gamer paint?
Oh there is gamer paint.
Wow, they really need to make it like toxic yellow.
Those eggs belong in a museum.
Okay.
Freedom!
Gina, I need some help.
Gina?
Where are you?
Gina, I need some help.
Goddammit, I knew that was gonna happen.
Gina!
Ah!
You pull yourself.
What do you mean push you up?
I'm not gonna do the work for you.
Yeah, right.
Alright, come on.
Come on girly.
I don't know.
Push!
Hello.
You found me!
Oh, this one down here?
Yeah, skip on over there.
I'll run.
Doctor Joan.
Indiana Joan.
How do you know where this is?
He is a jolly boy.
Watch out for traps.
Shiva Shrine!
Talk to Aran.
Sound real like a Minecraft villager there.
Anything behind?
Nope.
We got the Amogus.
All that for an Amogus.
I swear.
Your uncle.
I mean he almost died.
You almost died Aran.
Like, who would have gotten you out?
Really?
All of that and you're not even gonna come with us?
This little punk ass.
I should have left you in there.
Yeah, he was done for.
He was donezo.
He got kidnapped and everything.
Exactly.
But no.
He's gotta stay here and research.
And do...
Do scientific things.
Historical things.
Patooey.
Ok, let's go see if we can find a melee weapon.
To then open up the box that's down here.
He belongs in a museum.
Yeah, we will.
Do you think this one will work?
Let's try it.
Alright.
Grabbed a whip.
Yeah, exactly.
Alright, we have a little box here.
Let's go.
Alright.
Move Gina!
Gina, you're in my way.
Out of the way woman.
That was some hot cash.
Is anyone still alive out here?
I don't know actually.
I'm going to heal.
I'm gonna take their bandages.
Heal, heal.
Steal, steal.
I think everybody's still dead.
This one's kinda funky.
What were they playing?
Polo?
Just in case.
The lobotomizer.
Yeah, everyone looks pretty dead.
Okay.
To Sanan.
They're gonna take the mallet.
Okay.
Everybody take your weapon of choice.
Grab the weapon that speaks to you.
From the soul.
Let's go see what that... There was that one area that said that we could climb up with my whip.
I do think it was just like a vantage point.
But we can still see.
It was like right there I believe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was one on the other side too.
You got a chainsaw.
Ah, I can just take their food and stuff.
Oh, I could have distracted them.
This is like super cozy.
This is like such a nice little...
Nice little hangout spot.
Hey, Gina, you should come up here.
It's great.
Oh, but you can't.
Your tiny arms can't bring you up here.
Sucks for Gina.
Anything over here?
No, just more hiding spots.
Anything in here?
Nope, I'm stuck.
Gina, I'm stuck.
No girls allowed, yeah.
No girls allowed in our fort.
Wait, what about me then?
What are you talking about?
Come on Gina, let's go home.
Only Minky allowed.
Ok.
Only Minky is allowed in our establishment.
And there was a fast travel.
I wonder if we can use it.
I don't remember where it was at though.
It was like right over here, no?
I think.
Minky is cool so it's ok?
Oh, sorry, wrong button.
Let's just go this way.
Minky is only... Minky is only...
I think it's a pretty straight path from here even if I don't hit up a...
Oh wait, but there was a fast travel at the tree house.
I think.
Oh gosh, I can't remember.
Wait, fast travel.
Perfect.
I'm docking, I'm docking.
The secret of the tigers.
Oh, there are the black circles on the map.
Ah, I see it.
So we are going to the village.
Yippee!
This way?
Yep.
Bye Jones.
Who said that to me?
Was that Gina?
Hi.
Donation box.
I still...
Oh, there is a medicinal hut.
I still haven't figured out how to unlock those.
Fifteen!
Fifteen bottles.
Goodness gracious.
Why are we taking a picture of?
Sneak.
Expensive ass books.
I know.
Come on.
They really did just say Indiana Jones.
It's hard to say.
Wait.
I remember now.
This is the highest point of the mountain.
This is the old area of Sukhothai hundreds of years ago.
This should be the main stream.
It was steeper back then.
This should be the current location of the Mahathat temple.
Mahathat temple.
Of course.
Thank you!
Also, about your...
Oh, that's not money.
You got lucky.
About your nephew.
Troy Baker is doing his best.
He's trying real hard.
I can't understand Indy's Thai.
I don't think I would be able to either.
It sounds really stiff.
Fried egg!
The kid who vanished.
We did it!
Wait, what do you want to tell me about?
I don't trust any of you saying it's not very far from here.
Cat!
Oh cat!
Fried egg is the cat!
That's so cute!
Haunted demon?
Move out of the way, Indy!
Wait, but I wanted to meet the demon.
What do you mean the demon's final breath?
The cat.
Fried egg is so cute.
We should take a look around Wat Sa Sa.
Maybe there's some truth to the story.
Lost in the past.
I think I'm good.
I think I might actually call it here today.
Actually, let's get to... Let's go to this and go to a new place, right?
Find the... No, I'm not finding the cave.
No, I want to... Speak to Pailin.
Yeah, that's what we're doing.
Let's do that.
Where is she?
Oh, she's over there.
Is the game fun, Minto?
Yeah, I love this game.
It's so much fun.
This game is crowded.
It's packed with stuff.
There's just so much to do in this game.
It's insane.
Hello.
Yeah, what's up?
That doesn't sound good.
It's basically an RPG.
As far as I know.
The places are pretty well researched too.
They put a lot of care into this game.
That explosion was even bigger than the first one.
What do you think they're doing?
Something caught their eye and they're blasting their way to it.
Digging is slow work.
Delicate.
Vos must be desperate.
Desperate enough to destroy our country in order to get what he wants.
I'll find out what they're up to.
Makes you hungry.
Hungry?
This is like the next part of...
Like this is... Wait, stop, stop, stop.
I'm trying to... I guess we're on the blessed pearl.
But why isn't it... Hold on.
Why is it being weird?
Okay, there we go.
I was trying to go up and down, but it wouldn't let me.
Oh no, the Wat Mahatat is where we need to go.
Technically, for the main story.
This is the one... Gosh, that's so far!
And then, the demon in the cave.
I don't truly... I think we're good on that one.
Um...
I feel like this one is good too, though.
Yeah, I think we'll save it for next time, though.
The study of fear and the blessed pearl.
I was hoping maybe we would get out of this area.
But it doesn't seem to be the case.
Um...
Study and fear is a good one.
Okay, I'll do it.
Her embroidered eyepatch looks so nice.
I know, right?
We got jackpot, though.
We did... We did... do pretty well, I'd say.
The giant snake part was perfect for Year of the Snake.
Loving the game so far.
Right!
It was!
I could keep going, but I feel like I shouldn't.
I feel like I think I'll stop here.
And what?
I don't know how many more streams left of this game.
I have no idea.
Thanks, Dry Princess!
Maybe two or three?
Maybe?
I have no idea.
Hello!
Taking pictures of the naked people?
Cooking.
Let them cook.
I like just messing around with the people, though.
I like just running around and seeing what's going on.
Hello.
They all give me such... such looks.
That's so... What am I reaching for?
Oh, the star fruit.
You got this!
I want some coconut now.
Will this game be counted to your finished games of 2025?
I think so.
I'm finishing it in 2025.
It's a bit of a loophole, but...
You know, if I wanted it counted towards 2024, I would have put it under 2024.
I'd count it.
It counts.
Well then, let me find a safe point.
I want the little hat icon, you know.
Let's...
We'll go towards the explosion thing and maybe when we get into the boat, it'll save for us.
Hopefully.
That's not my boat.
That's my boat.
Fast travel.
You know, whatever.
Let's fast travel to...
Uh...
Where?
Oh, no, no.
Steady in here.
Fast travel to the tree house.
I think we'll be good.
It's pretty safe there, actually, too.
Fast tree house.
Tree house.
What?
Wait, no!
Wait, I went to the secret armory.
Mint, when are your streams?
I post my schedule on Twitter.
I post my schedule in the community tab and there's a little waiting room on my channel that has my schedules, too.
Wait.
Why won't the map work?
I'm trying to check the map.
The tree house.
Oh, wait.
Maybe it's the black circles.
Oh, never mind.
I misunderstood.
That's my fault.
We can go to the...
Whatever.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Sorry I called you mint.
No!
I'm not upset.
I'm just joking.
Don't haunt me.
Actually, please haunt me more.
Okay, I don't know which one that...
I don't know which one... The very one at the bottom.
I wish I could... I wish the fast travels also had names.
I don't know which one it was.
Maybe it's the...
I don't think the hut is closer at all.
It's that dock you went past and didn't stop at.
Maybe it's the armory.
Let's try it out.
Yeah, I think this is it.
Oh, no.
Actually, this works.
Because it's right over there that we need to get to.
This one would have been a little bit closer.
But we don't know what that is.
So...
This works, baby.
Alright, we're not going into the armory, though...
We could...
I feel like there's probably a uniform in here.
You know what I mean?
We'll see.
Did it save?
I can't tell.
Did it save, you guys?
I don't know.
Bye-bye.
It did?
Okay.
Anyway, this was fun.
Less than a minute ago.
Okay, perfect.
I hope you guys are enjoying the game, too.
Maybe...
Next stream?
Stream after?
We will finish.
I'll do my best.
I still have quite a bit to go.
People were saying that last stream I was at the halfway point or something.
There's still so much.
Two streams, I think.
Okey-dokey.
Otsuminto, everybody.
I'll see you guys...
Thank you for the superchat.
I'll see you guys later tomorrow.
I play Devil May Cry 3.
I play more of that.
I have quite a few games that I'm trying to finish up.
Finish up, finish up.
And then we can move on to other stuff.
Thank you.
This game has been a lot of fun to watch.
Otsuminto, thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks for the streaming, though.
Thanks for watching.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye bye.
Good night, good night.
Otsuminto, bye bye.